today is november 1st 2021 so it's time
for another monthly update video and
we're going to talk a bit about what
we've got coming up in november what
went on in the very long but busy month
of october and i always like to begin
with three big things and they are three
pretty significant things this time
around number one big thing number one i
am joining the
riverwest radio drive time show in the
prime time of 4 to
5 30 p.m every other wednesday the
the host asked me if i would come on as
a co-host and that's about all the
amount of time that i can make for it
but it's kind of a foray into
doing some more general type of radio
big thing number two and this is a
really big thing a worldwide event that
goes on an entire week my wife andy
shaka is running women's
entrepreneurship week which is centered
here in milwaukee but is available to
people all over the world a whole bunch
of really cool free events running from
monday the 8th of november all the way
to saturday the 13th there's a ton of
things you can see the link below so if
you're at all interested in it you know
by the way it doesn't it's not just for
women anybody who's interested in
entrepreneurship or women's issues can
join in on it as well anybody can find
an event that they would be quite
interested in
big thing number three people have been
asking for this for a long time and we
are finally
two steps away from actually making it
happen and those steps will happen early
in this month
we're going to be putting out some merch
for the youtube channel for me dr sadler
and it's the kind of stuff that i think
people will really get into so those are
the big things coming up this this month
let's talk about what happened in
october
so before we even get to talking about
videos or podcasts or things like that
october had a lot going on and let me
just tell you what some of the things
that were going on
were
in my classes of course it was mid-term
which means that students are kind of
panicking they're a little bit more
panicky in our you know covid19
situation where we're doing things still
remotely and i think people are kind of
worn out i also got
as did my wife the double whammy of a
flu shot and coveted booster on the same
day and man did that have some side
effects that
cut a good bit into some of the things
that i wanted to do this month we've
also been spending some time
going to events here
in the milwaukee area where you know
members of the milwaukee symphony
orchestra so we went to a couple
concerts my oldest daughter was in a
musical so i you know went there with my
mother-in-law
and there were a few other events as
well but the biggest thing of course for
october was stoicon which andy and i
both ran with the help of a few other
people
videos from that will be coming out
later on this month in november in the
modern stoicism channel not in my
channel
and that was a lot of work um it went
quite well with a few technical
difficulties
but for an online international event it
was it went pretty pretty good with a
lot of speakers a lot of different
panels um
i've been teaching my academic classes
building them out they're all online so
there's a good bit of that i took on a
number of new clients in october
and i've been you know building out some
some platforms and doing things like
that and doing some writing on medium as
well and so that took up a considerable
amount of time
videos i got five half hour hegel videos
i probably would have gotten six if we
hadn't gotten the inoculations
that took out uh a bit of my energy and
and for a couple days made me pretty
sore
um wisdom for life we released those
videos um classic metal class 12 we
released that one and there was
something that i did that i think a lot
of people got a kick out of going by
views and comments and that was the you
know the evil memes that have been going
around like evil aristotle vice ethics
evil this and that well i i did a evil
saddler meme and it kind of caught on
and so i decided to do an evil saddler
video and
that was quite well received so i think
i'll be doing some more of those
i've been shooting a lot of
speculative fiction studies videos from
my ursula k le guin earth c class and
i've been releasing those we are
actually you know in the channel we're a
bit behind all the videos that i've
produced and that's that's basically all
we did in the channel i didn't get the
book reviews i didn't get to caption
contests i didn't get to other things in
part because of the stoichon and the
midterms and vaccinations and all the
work that i've been doing podcast i did
a lot of sandler shorts and i also put
them into a
curated medium page i'll put a link to
that below so you can take a look and
see all the different shorts i'm going
to be adding more information to that
to tell you all about each of those
those are like three to five minute
podcast episodes talking about some
classic or contemporary wisdom and
unpacking it for you
and i've been doing some of the sadler's
lectures as well we went through
leo tolstoy's what is art i had four
podcast episodes on that i've been
cranking away at the miguel de uno muno
tragic sense of life because i've got an
existentialism class coming up next
semester that will be using it and that
is basically all that we did during
october
very very busy month
i'm looking forward to having a break
coming up this this
next month of november
november is going to be a busy month and
it's very very packed at the beginning
we kind of taper off as we get you know
towards thanksgiving which if you're
american you know nothing gets done over
thanksgiving and if you're not american
you should probably expect that during
the last week of november you're not
going to see an awful lot other than you
know maybe releasing videos and podcasts
and stuff like that so on the 3rd at 4
p.m these are all central time i will be
coming on for the very first time well
it's actually not the very first time on
the drive time show i've been there as a
guest now i'm going to be a co-host and
that will be new for me you can listen
to it anywhere in the world if you want
to just by going to riverwest radio
you know wxrw
104.1 fm and you know you can click the
site below that i'll put in the video
description and you can find it and
listen to me chatting about the daily
events with my
uh host uh martin hallinger uh it should
be should be quite interesting he's
running the board so all i got to do is
chit chat and that's it
on the 4th at 12 p.m i will be having
the first and only live reading of this
month it just isn't working out as far
as thursdays go for other weeks on the
6th at 12 p.m that's a saturday we will
have our monthly ama that's ask me
anything session done with youtube live
following that on the 6th at 2pm i'll
have my patreon exclusive philosophy
chat if you want to be part of that
that's a little bit more intimate
you know it's video conferencing well
then you want to become a patreon
supporter and you want to support at the
level that gets you that as a perk
on the 10th that's a wednesday at 5 00
p.m we will have the
half hour hegel q a and discussion
anybody can show up to that that is
something that is underwritten by
supporters of the half-hour hegel
project by that time we will also be in
as i mentioned women's entrepreneurship
week a lot of really great sessions
coming up for that so you know the link
for that is below check it out there's a
lot of really cool stuff coming up
on the fifth i should also mention at 4
pm i forgot about this
andy and i are going to be going on
massimo's podcast which will be
streaming live to talk about stoicism
marriage relationships
you know how to handle
disagreement how to make your life
together better all these sorts of
things that may be of interest to you
and i'm sure there'll be a video coming
out
for that later in the month
on the 13th at 12 p.m another saturday
i'll be doing another one of my
political theory and practice
discussions have to determine what the
actual topic is going to be haven't
decided on that yet but i'll be figuring
that out before too long
on the 17th i'll be coming back on to
riverwest radio that wednesday at 4 p.m
for the drive time show
on the 20th which is a saturday at
12 p.m
scott truly and i will be doing our
classic metal class and this time we are
going to be talking in particular
about the interconnection between
uh heavy metal
music videos television shows before mtv
became a huge
matter a going concern there's a lot of
back story there that prepared the way
for mtv becoming one of the premier
places
on the 25th at 6 pm
we'll be doing the milwaukee stoic
fellowship meeting that's a chapter
meeting and then finally on the 27th at
12 p.m and at 1 1 30 p.m we will be
doing worlds of speculative fiction this
time around i am doing the novel and it
is a very long novel anathem by
stevenson that i think some people have
been looking forward to for a long time
so those are the things we've got coming
up as far as events go in november um
videos i'm going to be you know trying
to get
get you know up to six half hour hegel
videos done i like to hit that quota if
i can each month but it's a little bit
challenging from time to time
um i'll also be doing some of the
overdue book reviews that i've been
trying to get to but not succeeding um
much more of the
you know the green earthy speculative
fiction videos you can expect those
coming out i don't know if i'm going to
do any core concept videos i might i
might not you know
we'll see how many i can get to there
will be at least one evil saddler video
i'm not gonna say when it'll happen but
it will definitely happen since people
got into that and i'll probably do some
personal videos and some caption
contests and stuff like that depending
on how much time i have for for doing
things um podcasts the sadler's lecture
podcast i'm finishing up with miguel de
una munoz tragic sense of life we will
also be doing of course
some some other things so i'm thinking
leo stoves all things are possible
because i'm getting ready for that
existentialism class and judith jarvis
thompson's the trolley problem i put out
some videos on that a while back i'm
going to take those videos and convert
them into podcast episodes people have
been looking forward to those
and then we'll do some more shorts as
well i don't know exactly who we're
going to do in shorts but we'll figure
that out the other two big things to
talk about
you know i'm going to be doing some more
writing in medium and quora hopefully
i'm going to be trying to grind away at
those and you'll probably see some
courses coming out in my teachable
academy
and in listenable depending on how much
time i find myself with to get things
done
finally merch
we haven't yet decided what platform
we're going with but i've already been
building some designs
and
we're gonna start out with it and and
the idea is you know christmas is coming
up people want to buy presents sometimes
for others sometimes for themselves so
it would be cool to actually have some
stuff that can show your support show
your interest and make some clever jokes
you know at philosophers and perhaps
even my my own expense so you can keep
an eye out for that in the near future
and that's pretty much it for the month
of november i hope all of you have a
great month and hope to see some of you
in these online events like i said
everything you know click the video you
know show more the video description and
you'll see these dates and various links
to things so i'm going to sign off right
here
you